You're clearly such a strong person,
but why did you decide to join the military
in the first place?
Oh, that's a funny story.
I decided to join the military because I have a cousin.
She was in the Air Force.
Now you heard me, I said she.
She was my role model.
I saw her in the uniform.
I saw her going places all over,
and it looked so glamorous,
and it looked like, in my eyes,
that the military was the place to be.
And she looked, not just, she looked so studious.
She looked important,
and I wanted to be like that.
So that's one of the reasons why I joined.
(audience applauding)
Once you got in it, and you saw how it really functioned,
and you got onto the inside,
and you weren't just looking at the outside,
how did you find that women were treated?
So I love the military.
I wanna say that first.
I love the United States military,
but (Donna laughs) actually being in,
we as women, we go to the frontline.
We are in war,
and we're not recognized.
There was times in the beginning when I first joined
I didn't even get a chance to do the job
that I was trained for.
We don't even get recognized outside the military.
We do every single job.
Every single job that the military offers, we do.
(audience applauding)
Is it true that you had an interesting interaction
with a veteran after you returned home?
So not just on the frontlines but back at home.
Oh yes.
My wife and I, we were,
we pulled up to the gas station,
and I have disabled veteran plates.
I have a wounded warrior sticker in my front window.
Obviously a veteran looking vehicle.
And a gentleman was behind me and pumping gas,
and he finished pumping his gas and pulled in front.
And he came to salute me and said,
make sure you tell your husband
that I said thank him for his service.
In turn, I turned to him and I told him, you know what?
Thank you for your service,
and I'm the veteran.
So.
(audience applauding)
And what was his reaction in that moment?
I think he was shocked and embarrassed,
and he just drove off.
I first got to know about Wounded Warrior
about 10 years ago.
A friend of mine is a big participator,
and it brought the project to my attention.
And when I see the way your life has transformed with them,
this is so much more than a topical association.
It's like, it seemed like they did give you a door
that you walked through,
and on the other side of that door
was a life waiting for you.
Let me tell you.
I can't do anything,
but when I think of Wounded Warrior Project,
I smile because, just like you said,
Wounded Warrior Project is not just an organization.
Yes.
It's an organization that empowers women.
This organization literally gave me my life back.
It didn't gimme my life back.
It actually boosted and kicked forward my life.
Without Wounded Warrior Project,
I probably wouldn't be here.
Wounded Warrior Project gave me a community, gave me family.
When you're in the military, you gain a family.
And sometimes being injured and getting out of the military,
you kinda lose those connections, lose that family.
And every single event I've ever been on
in Wounded Warrior Project,
it's like going to a family reunion,
and I have that family again.
I have those connections.
It gives you that comradery.
And without Wounded Warrior Project,
I know myself and a lot of others wouldn't be here.
Well, I'm so glad that you are here, Donna.
And on International Women's Day,
your fierceness, your strength, your life choices,
your life attitude, choosing to go and serve and protect,
choosing to be on a high road
when every other option seems probably easier,
you are such an inspiration.
Thank you.
And I'm so glad to meet you and hear your story.
Thank you, Donna.
Thank you.
And to learn more about how Wounded Warrior Project
is helping lift up female veterans,
visit more WoundedWarriorProject.org/EmpowerWomenVets.
Thank you, Donna.
(upbeat music)